The people in the village say they're scraping together money, so let's put it out there
quickly.How many people can do it today?Let's do it in a flashy way.I
didn't think we'd do it again,
but just in case no one can see it.After that, it's a
party of luck.  I can't hear a voice, all the different sounds have
disappeared.When the enemy attacks, I
say that I don't want to go deeper into the human world, but in the end, even if I'm just a
child, I decide to follow my emotions and act on my
emotions.  I've
put magic on my head, but
I'm dead. It's an
Elder Dwarf's equipment. It has
great defensive power, but it's a waste to
have so many bows.
[Music]
When I first learned it from Emma, ​​I
wasn't sure if I'd be able to use it properly,
but now.  Now that the
sound I'm used to has returned, this arrow will definitely
hit me, but I won't take my life.One last thing, though, I'll say I'll
never do it from now on.
[Music]